mais pourra me connaissez vous la
nouvelle et kane ouvert mais
monsieur du snrtc calmez vous les prenez
une grande respiration c'est gratuit
maintenant nous écoutons casimir a
quitté l'île aux enfants pour tous
jouent ses 19 ans que dites vous est ce
que je viens de dire qu'on soit voyons
casimir est parti me vous l'avez vu
partir vraiment mais bien sûr je l' ai
vu de mes yeux comme je vous vois c'est
notre casimir une autre académie russe à
nous tous je vais même parlé je lui dis
tu nous quittes
et kate il répondu ouais et alors il
vous ne lui avait rien demandé dont je
suis bien évidemment j'ai rajouté de 7 à
propos qu'il fait partie de mes qualités
pourquoi et quand il répondu ma maison
est hantée je pars je m'attendais la
ligue on veut téléphoner lorsque vous
aurez chasser le fond
pourtant il m'apparut sincèrement
l'effrayer
non mais moi moi je sais pourquoi ah bon
parce que toi aussi tu crois aux
fantômes les pugnière casimir n'a parlé
de grattements suspects dans sa maison
écoutez le mieux c'est d'aller voir
absolument dépêchez vous allez voir et
revenez vite nous dire ce qui se passe
je voudrais pas y aller tout seul dit
monsieur du snuff ouest à issy juillet
mois nous partons à la chasse aux
fantômes aller
[Musique]
tout à l'air apparemment cadre tu
t'attendais tu à être accueillis par des
fantômes et bien sûr que nous mais je
voudrais quand même savoir quel est ce
bruit qui a fait fuir casimir alors nous
allons rester ici pour enquêter oui et
bien en fait d' enquête je crois qu'il
serait beaucoup plus utile de faire un
peu de ménage mettre le réseau au drame
à rire
tu entends guy françois mais j'ai
entendu mes partons vite non non je lis
julie non non non non non il faut
s'écouter que dirait monsieur du snob
non non alors au moins 15 selon nous
mais tu as raison cachée nous cachions
nous là nous sommes très bien nous
verrons
japon ancien grand maximum
un vraiment incroyable vraiment l'équipe
qu'elle ne mène pas trop le raccordement
de plus l'enseigné de renard pour
aboutir à de vieilles malles et d'objets
positionne
enfin c'est à vous dégoûter de revenir à
l'air libre
je suis
curieuse maison
désordre auquel toupin ce sont les
objets qui viennent jeter
[Musique]
ya quelqu'un ici
au cas quelqu'un besoin vous y trouve
encore
bonjour monsieur le renard
salut je m'appelle né en à moi je suis
julie et moi je m'appelle françois ouais
ouais vous n'êtes pas des passionnés du
ménage à ce que je vois c'est que ce
n'est pas notre maison nous c'est celle
de notre ami casimir casimir le
descendant du roi casimir news premier
exactement mais vous le connaissez vrai
que réputation seulement et où est il
casey mais allez l'appeler pas il est
parti aujourd'hui
mais pour toujours non mais depuis
quelques jours il vous entendais creuser
votre tunnel alors il est parti chez sa
tante adélaïde croyant qu'il s'agissait
d'un fantôme et il nous a demandé
d'essayer de capturer ce soi-disant
fantôme
[Rires]
les enquêtes montrent aux gens d'y
coller casimir youth et épreuve ah bon
parce que nous vous n'avez jamais peur
moi jamais il est surtout pas des choses
qui n'existent pas et comme les fantômes
n'existe pas pas
et
qu'est ce que c'est en tout cas pas des
photos n'est ce pas c'est vrai puisque
il n'existe pas en tunisie vous - il ne
faut pas plaisanter avec ses changements
pour quelqu un de ces courageux il ya eu
tellement peur oui
en tout cas moi je suis très inquiet je
me demande qui peut faire ce bruit
alors tout va bien aussi